TRUTH FROM A COMMUNIST COUNTRY?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, RICH.
DR. MARTY MAKARY NOW FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR AND PROFESSOR AT
THE JOHNS HOPKINS UNIVERSITY
SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING ME.
MY FIRST QUESTION FOR YOU IS
WHEN WE POINT TO THE SCIENCE OF
THIS, HOW COMMON IS IT FOR
PEOPLE WORKING IN A LABORATORY
LIKE THAT IN WUHAN TO GET SO
SICK SHE NEED TO BE
HOSPITALIZED AND WORKING ON
SOMETHING THAT THEY DID THAT TO
THEM?
HOW COMMON IS THAT?
>> LAB ACCIDENTS ARE VERY
COMMON.
THIS INFORMATION THAT THREE LAB
WORKERS WERE SEEN AND EVALUATED
AND HOSPITALIZED IS ENOUGH
CIRCUMSTANTIAL EVIDENCE NOW IT
IS NO LONGER A LAB HYPOTHESIS.
IT IS THE DEFAULT CONCLUSION.
WE CAN CALL FOR MORE
INVESTIGATIONS ALL WE WANT.
WE WON’T GET WITNESS PROTECTION
FOR THOSE KEY SOURCES.
WE WON’T GET THE ORIGINAL
SAMPLES.
THEY’VE PROBABLY BEEN DESTROYED.
WE PROBABLY HAVE ALL THE INFO
WE NEED RIGHT NOW.
>> Harris: WE WOULD HAVE TO
ALSO LOCATE ALL THE SCIENTISTS.
CHINA IS NOT PLAYING BALL.
WHAT ROLE DO YOU EXPECT THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION COULD
PLAY IN THIS WHETHER THEY KNEW
THEY WERE PLAYING THAT ROLE OR
NOT?
>> I DON’T THINK THEY COULD.
THEY LED A SHAM INVESTIGATION
AND PUT THE FUNDER OF THE LAB
ON THE INVESTIGATION COMMITTEE,
WHICH IS A COMPLETE CONFLICT OF
INTEREST.
LOOK, EVEN IF THEY DID  THAIN
VEST GAITION PROPERLY I THINK
THE EVIDENCE HAS BEEN DESTROYED
AND WE WON’T SEE THE WITNESS
PROTECTION NEEDED.
I THINK THAT ENOUGH
CIRCUMSTANTIAL EVIDENCE IS
THERE NOW THERE IS A CONCLUSION
THAT CAN BE MADE.
I’VE MADE A CONCLUSION KNOWING
HOW COMMON LAB ACCIDENTS ARE.
I THINK IT’S NO LONGER A LAB
HYPOTHESIS.
I THINK THAT’S EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> Harris: SO DR. MAKARY, WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THIS, WHAT’S
IMPORTANT THAT WE KNOW AFTER
ALL THIS TIME?
HOW MUCH COULD IT HAVE SAVED US
IF WE HAD KNOWN WHAT WE KNOW
EVEN NOW CIRCUMSTANTIALLY?
>> LOOK, IF WE KNEW THE ORIGIN
I DON’T THINK IT WOULD HAVE
CHANGED ANYTHING WITH THIS
OUTBREAK.
INITIAL DOCTOR SOUNDED THE
ALARM.
THREE DETAINED BY POLICE, ONE
OF THEM WAS FORCED TO SIGN A
STATEMENT.
THAT’S PUBLIC INFORMATION.
SO I DON’T THINK IT WOULD HAVE
CHANGED ANYTHING.
IN TERMS OF FUTURE PANDEMICS WE
SHOULDN’T BE CHARACTERIZING
VIRUSES THAT LIVE IN THE ZOO
AND NOT THE KINGDOM.
A MILLION VIRUSES IN THE WORLD.
WHY DO WE FUND RESEARCH TO
BRING THEM INTO A LAB AND
CHARACTERIZE THEM?
IT DOESN’T MAKE SENSE.
>> Harris: NOVEMBER WAS SO FAR
FROM WHERE WE SAW OUR FIRST
CASES IN THE BEGINNING OF 2020.
WOULD THAT LEAD TIME HAVE
HELPED US AT ALL?
WE’LL NEVER KNOW.
RAND PAUL NOW SAYS HE WILL NOT
GET A COVID VACCINE SHOT UNTIL
HE SEES IT IS MORE EFFECTIVE
THAN IMMUNITY.
>> SHOULD THEY FORCE PEOPLE TO
GET VACCINATED THAT SURVIVE IT.
I THINK WE SHOULD HAVE A CHOICE
WHETHER WE TAKE A VACCINE OR
NOT.
FRANKLY ALL STUDIES SHOW I HAVE
JUST AS GOOD OF IMMUNITY AS THE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN VACCINATED.
>> Harris: DR. MAKARY, YOUR
RESPONSE TO THAT.
>> HE IS RIGHT.
THE STUDIES DO SHOW AND THERE
IS MORE EVIDENCE ON NATURAL
IMMUNITY THAN THERE IS ON
VACCINATED IMMUNITY BECAUSE
NATURAL IMMUNITY HAS BEEN
AROUND A LOT LONGER AND IT IS
EFFECTIVE AND WORKS.
WE DON’T SEE REINFECTIONS AT
ANY GREAT DEGREE.
SCIENTIFIC LOGIC IS RATION NA.
HE IS A DOCTOR AND A SMART
DOCTOR.
I’VE TALKED TO HIM.
IT MAKES SENSE.
WHY DO WE ALWAYS DISTINGUISH
VACCINATED AND UNVACCINATED AS
IF NATURAL IMMUNITY DOES NOT
EXIST?
THAT’S ULTIMATELY I THINK ONE
OF THE GREAT FAILURES OF OUR
MEDICAL LEADERSHIP IS IGNORING
NATURAL IMMUNITY WHICH CHANGES
EVERYTHING.
>> Harris: I’M WONDERING HOW DO
PEOPLE GET IT TWICE?
>> LOOK, WE KNOW BREAKTHROUGH
INFECTIONS HAPPEN AFTER
VACCINATED IMMUNITY.
THEY ARE RARE AND MILD.
THAT’S THE SAME WITH NATURAL
IMMUNITY AND THE GIANT STUDY IN
DENMARK WAS 6/10 OF 1% AND MOST
OF THOSE CASES ARE MILD.
JUST BECAUSE SOMEBODY TESTS
POSITIVE DOESN’T MEAN WE HAVE A
HEALTH PROBLEM.
THE PCR TEST CAN DETECT AS FEW
AS 10 PARTICLES IN YOUR NOSE.
IT MAY MEAN YOUR IMMUNE SYSTEM
WORKED TO FEND OFF THE
INFECTION.
>> Harris: MAYBE CHINA KNEW
THINGS WE DIDN’T.
THEY STARTED TESTING PEOPLE ON
THE OPPOSITE ENDS, NOT THEIR
NOSE BUT THEIR BUMS IF YOU WILL
JUST TO BE DELICATE.
DR. FAUCI AND CDC HEAD DIRECTOR
SAY THEY UNDERSTAND WHY PEOPLE
ARE AFRAID TO REMOVE THEIR
MASKS.
>> YOU CAN UNDERSTAND THAT WHEN
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING A
CERTAIN TREND FOR A
CONSIDERABLE PERIOD OF TIME
THAT IT MAY TAKE TIME FOR THEM
TO ADJUST.
>> NOT EVERYBODY WILL FEEL LIKE
IT’S TIME TO RIP OFF THEIR MASK.
FOR 16 MONTHS WE’RE SAYING WEAR
THEM TO PROTECT THEM.
NOW IT WILL GET HARD TO GET
BACK TO LIFE AS WE KNEW IT
WITHOUT THESE MASKS.
>> Harris: I’M OLD ENOUGH TO
REMEMBER BECAUSE IT HAS ONLY
BEEN A FEW MONTHS WHEN DR.
FAUCI SAID ON 60 MINUTES
OVERTIME, THE ONLINE VERSION OF
60 MINUTES.
YOU WATCH IT WHEN THE SHOW IS
OVER AND SOMETIMES YOU GET
LITTLE DRIPS LIKE WELL, MASKS
AREN’T REALLY THE END ALL, BE
ALL.
HE WAS NOT REALLY ENCOURAGING
PEOPLE TO WEAR MASKS.
MAYBE THE MIXED MESSAGING
PLAYED A ROLE IN ALL THIS?
PEOPLE’S PERCEPTION WHETHER OR
NOT THEY SHOULD TAKE THEM OFF
OR KEEP THEM ON?
>> WHEN MANY OF US HAD A PUBLIC
ARGUMENT AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE PANDEMIC HE THOUGHT IT
WOULD PETER OUT LIKE  SARS DID.
IT DIDN’T POOP OUT IN CHINA.
THAT WAS A MISTAKE.
WHERE WE ARE NOW THE IS CDC
DROPPED THIS WITHOUT ANY
WARNING OR NOTICE.
THEY GIVE US NOTICE FOR SCHOOL
GUIDANCE, CAMP GUIDANCE,
EVERYTHING ELSE FOR THE VACCINE
ALLOCATION GUIDANCE BUT THIS
THEY JUST DROPPED ON FOLKS.
NOW THEY ARE BACK PEDALING AND
SAYING IT’S REASONABLE YOU MAY
WANT TO CONTINUE TO WEAR A MASK.
THEY IGNORED NATURAL IMMUNITY
TO YOUR EARLIER POINT, HARRIS.
AND AS A RESULT, THEY
MISCALCULATED THE HIGH DEGREE
OF POPULATION IMMUNITY OUT
THERE TODAY.
AND WHEN YOU’VE GOT 80 TO 85%
OF ADULTS IMMUNE WHERE WE ARE
TODAY IN THE UNITED STATES
BECAUSE ROUGHLY HALF OF THE
UNVACCINATED PEOPLE HAVE
NATURAL IMMUNITY YOU’LL SEE
SIGNIFICANT SLOWING.
THEY WERE CAUGHT OFFGUARD AND
RELEASED THIS QUICKLY BECAUSE
OF PUBLIC DEMAND.
>> Harris: ALWAYS A PLEASURE TO